bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
football américain des templiers
d'elancourt ont été corrigés par les
dauphins de nice samedi à domicile lors
de la 3e journée du championnat élite
le score est lourd 33 à 13 les détails
dans ce magazine tennis handisport à 29
ans le rambo lite un ol qui nous visent
une première participation aux jeux
paralympiques de rio et pour concussion
qui se déroulera du 7 au 18 septembre le
tennisman sera notre habiter dans
quelques instants sur ce plateau basket
féminin le chesnay versailles 78 vacillé
mais l'équipe est sortie victorieuse de
son duel contre douvres ce dimanche les
yvelinois se sont imposés 69 à 68 et
conserve la tête du classement de
nationale 3 reportage à suivre
et puis nous parlerons également du
marathon des sables 2016 des yvelinois
participeront à la compétition qui se
déroulera du 8 au 18 avril dans le
sahara marocain
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football américain ont joué ce week-end
la troisième journée du championnat
élite c'est l'équivalent de la première
division
ce samedi les templiers d'elancourt ont
été terrassés par les dauphins de nice
le score 33 à 13 roma respini à pour le
montage
un match à vite oublier pour les
templiers d'elancourt ce samedi les
élans courtois se sont fait submerger
sur leur terrain par les dauphins de
nice à l'occasion de la 3e journée du
championnat élite
le score est sévère 33 13 les dauphins
sont pas venus ici de nice pour faire un
match nul au panama qui sont venus ils
étaient motivés
c'est une équipe explosive ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de joueurs donc je vous sors
intensité et ils jouent ensemble pour sa
part accueilli dans les cinq minutes
donc a eu cinq actions on prend des
essais donc après c'est dur de revenir
c'est une bonne équipe il faut le
respecter mais nous on a on arrêtait
plein d'occasions on a beaucoup plus de
talent ils veulent potentiel de ce qu'on
a montré ses seins
après cette contre-performance les
templiers pour à la quatrième place du
classement avec un bilan de deux
défaites et une victoire pour expliquer
ce début de saison en demi teinte les
cadres pour être le manque d'assiduité
aux entraînements on joue comme on
s'entraîne
dernièrement on a pas fait des supers
entraînements et ça se voit son terrain
si on veut performer plus mon
entraînement plus de discipline ce cas
en devenir prochain match pour les
templiers d'elancourt le dimanche 13
mars sur le terrain des cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône champion de france
2015 et invaincus depuis 17 matches
après le football américain on passe au
tennis
à 18 ans il a perdu sa jambe droite à la
suite d'un cancer des os aujourd'hui à
29 ans le robot litre johann qui nous
visent une place première participation
aux jeux paralympiques ou en tennis
depuis sa première licence handisport en
2008 son ascension est fulgurante les
blinois est passé du statut de débutant
à celui de sportifs de haut niveau en
moins de dix ans ce soir nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir à yoann qui ouvre
bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de parler des jo et de rio
alors voir revenir sur votre parcours
vous avez eu comme je le disais
précédemment une ascension fulgurante en
moins de dix ans vous êtes passé oui
j'ai statut de haut niveau oui
effectivement je suis parti je suis
parti de loin puisque je reviens donc
gvg une grave maladie donc à un cancer
des os un ostéosarcome j'ai perdu ma
jambe droite donc à l'âge de 18 ans et
un stage là on a besoin de se reprojeter
à travers des projets dans la vie dans
la vie privée dans la vie
professionnelle et sportive et grâce au
tennis j'ai pu vraiment me voilà me
retrouvais me reprendre confiance en moi
et j'ai pu valider certaines étapes je
suis pas vraiment deux parties non
classés jusqu'à atteindre le haut niveau
français puisque actuellement je suis
numéro 5 français et environ dans le top
30 mondial avant avant cette épreuve
vous étiez joueur de tennis mais pas
plus que ça pas plus que ça je faisais
du sport collectif en loisir notamment
du foot du hand ball également et non
non c'était une vraie découverte pour
moi le tennis le tennis handisport
donc vous avez gagné l'open du chili et
celui d'argentine en 2014
vous pouvez aussi arriver à ce niveau là
bas non non mais en même temps on
s'entraîne pour donc on fait des
sacrifices pour aller chercher ses
victoires pour aller chercher des points
qui vont nous permettre justement nous
qualifier pour des grands gc ans comme
les jeux les jeux paralympiques où les
coupes du monde et puis bah voila c'est
des sensations énormes de pouvoir porter
une coupe et de se dire de pouvoir
remercier aussi un staff et des
partenaires qui sont là aussi pour nous
soutenir et
et voilà c'est toujours une grande
émotion et quel était votre boisson
justement quand vous avez sauvé votre
premier trophée à l'émotion de voilà
j'ai toujours dit le travail paye quand
on veut on peut et ça a été aussi
vraiment une revanche sur ma vie d'avant
et de me dire que j'en suis là c'est pas
pour rien et que moi aussi j'étais
capable de gagner des tournois et
d'avancer d'avancé bon dans mon projet
sportif et l'émotion ça a été voilà de
penser aux gens qui me sont chers à ma
famille comme je disais à mon staff mes
partenaires tous ces gens qui croient en
moi en fait et vous sentez que le regard
de vos adversaires s'est transformé au
fur et à mesure des tournois des années
oui bah bien sûr après on est quand même
un petit milieu le tennis en fauteuil on
est à peu près moins de 4000 joueur
mondial au niveau soit un plan
international donc on se retrouve
régulièrement sur certaines compétitions
dans le monde entier et effectivement
commence à connaître un petit peu le
niveau de chacun donc effectivement le
tiguan qui où là il a commencé à ouvrir
à faire du bruit à faire ses preuves
donc oui effectivement il ya on commence
à se connaître ou et donc vous êtes
actuellement en course pour les jeux
paralympiques de 2016 les sélections
pour les qualifications sont programmées
en juin
est ce que vous êtes confiant sur cette
qualification vous êtes plutôt
pessimiste vous êtes auquel l'état en
soit maintenant je suis je suis je reste
optimiste je suis quelqu'un qui voit là
optimiste dans la vie donc voilà après
j'ai eu une super saison 2014 où j'ai
atteint atteint le top 20 mondial
vraiment le top 20 mondial ça représente
le haut niveau en tennis fauteuil donc
cdc l'autre des professionnels puisque
c'est les gens qui ne font que ça des
vrais athlètes de haut niveau
mon côté j'ai quand même une situation
professionnelle à gérer j'ai fait un
choix donc de voilà de ne pas laisser ma
carte professionnelle de côté et je suis
optimiste puisque lâché aux portes
je suis vraiment aux portes je suis
numéro 5 au jour d'aujourd'hui donc
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est une
mauvaise la mauvaise place mais il me
reste trois mois pour tout donner on
sait pas ce qui peut se passer et puis
avoir des blessures il peut y avoir
voilà problème technique je ne sais pas
moi je suis quelqu'un qui persévèrent et
je vais aller jusqu'au bout et
si je dois aller décrocher mon ticket je
l'aurais je l'aurais gagné ce ticket
voilà donc comme vous dites ce sera en
juin
la 'deadline' et vous entraînez
peut-être un petit peu plus que
d'habitude vous avez changé quelque
chose en dans vos techniques
d'entraînement sur ces dernières
semaines pour atteindre cet objectif
justement de des jeux je suis quasiment
resté sur le même planning dont je
m'entraîne à peu près 8 à 10 heures
toujours de sport donc par semaine donc
avec peu près six heures de tennis en
cours particuliers trois heures de près
par easy qu dans une salle et puis à peu
près un petit peu de coaching mental
bien évidemment un équilibre de vie à
côté une diététique
non après on a envie pas à moi je suis
pas un sportif professionnel comme je
dis j'ai besoin de mon activité trop
pour survivre mais besoin voilà par mémé
mais mes partenaires qui me finance on
va dire mais saison voilà je pense à pas
notamment de partenaires locaux
le club handisport des le club des
supporters handisport qui me soutiennent
également voilà l'entreprise sf6 donc
qu'une entreprise niveau national sinon
voilà il me des frais les frais mais
sinon j'ai envie pas et comment se se
dérouleront au semaine comment vous
décomposez votre semaine en fonction
justement du travail de l'entraînement
ça se passe ça se passe comment ces des
semaines de ministres monk
on va dire ça comme ça donc c'est trois
jours donc
au travail je travaille le lundi le
mardi matin le mercredi le jeudi matin
et ensuite j'ai le mardi après midi le
jeudi après midi le vendredi journée
complète dédiée à mon sport donc voilà
c'est des heures et des heures de sport
on voit qu'on n'est plus dans le loisir
courant il ya des fois il faut je suis
là pour m'entraîner et pour pour être
une condition optimale fils ni condition
physique optimale
on fait également des séances de
musculation oui oui je fais des séances
de musculation avec un préparateur
physique à peu près 3 4 heures par
semaine pour me développer le tronc le
physique pour pouvoir que je joue assis
dans un fauteuil bas nous on n'a plus
les jambes donc on sert plus les gens
sont obligés de se servir des bras pour
pousser le fauteuil est le plus
performant possible sur le terrain et le
physique est très importante et mr 10
sport c'est la technique qui fait la
différence au physique ou les deux les
deux allemands les deux puisque le
tennis est un sport technique donc et
mental il ya 50% c'est la technique 50%
du mental et bien développement physique
puisque on doit pousser on va dire un
fauteuil
ces panneaux jambes qui nous portent
donc en fait on est censé toujours en
train de rouler sur le terrain n'est
jamais à l'arrêt donc effectivement il
ya une part ou le cardio travaille
beaucoup et ça ça se prépare avant les
échéances des matchs donc d'avoir
vraiment le physique au bon moment si
vous ne partez pas are you cet été ce
sera une grosse déception
non je ne devrais pas comme l'a laissé
bien chance d'une vie peut-être qu'ils
passent change une vie ouais je suis pas
trop dans ces termes est là mais non
pour moi c'est aujourd'hui rien n'est
fait déjà du nez puis pour moi c'est une
belle revanche sur ma vie c'est vraiment
un beau projet de vie que j'ai su
construire je le redis chevré mans je
reviens de très très très loin
moi aujourd'hui je prends du plaisir
dans ce projet même même dans du sport
de haut niveau c'est quelque chose qui
me plaît ça m'a apporté des valeurs
j'arrive à quand même à transmettre
également des choses des valeurs aussi à
d'autres d'autres jeunes d'autres
accidentés ou d'autres jeunes issus de
maladie et ça en fait pour moi c'est une
c'est une vraie fierté
non je le verrais pas du tout comme un
échec et aujourd'hui je suis encore en
course donc je vous redis rsa
prochainement et si vous ne partez pas
cet été il y aura d'autres possibilités
à l'avenir il est encore jeune ouais je
suis encore jeune
bientôt trente donc du coup
il ya quatre ans oui après je peux me
projeter facilement pour les cadres la
prochaine olympiade qui se déroulera à
tokyo en 2020 là où je me dis qu'il ya
une vraie chance c'est que sur les
quatre meilleurs joueurs français il y
en aura deux certainement qu'ils vont
arrêter donc pourquoi pas j'ai réfléchi
je ne sais pas encore aujourd'hui
l'objectif sarlat ce trio et je me
consacre à cette échéance
et quel sera votre plus grand rêve le
plus grand rêve a déjà ses deux
fectivement c'est je pense qu'en tant
qu'athlète en tant qu'humain en tant que
sportif de haut niveau c'est vraiment
participer à des jeux des jeux
olympiques ou paralympiques je pense
qu'on arrive au graal comme je les ai
souvent dit voilà c'est une expérience
unique dans une vie
voilà ça ferait partie d'un de mes rêves
après j'en ai plein d'autres des rêves
qui sont peut-être plus facile à
réaliser
voilà je vais je vais rester sur le
domaine du sport mais ça reste
effectivement leur est favori en tout
cas auquel j'aimerais participer
on vous le souhaite en tout cas merci
voulais le passer sur ce plateau
continuera à suivre vos exploits sur tv
fil 78 après le tennis on ouvre une page
basket
en basket féminin le chesnay versailles
78 s'est imposé à domicile contre
douvres 69 à 68 victoire sur le fil qui
permet aux lillois de osi viennoise de
conserver la tête du classement de la
poule e de nationale 3 le montage est
signée romain yvos finition le chesnay
versailles a vacillé mais l'équipe est
sortie victorieuse de son duel contre au
nouveau ce dimanche
malmené pendant trois quart-temps les
yvelinois se sont imposés à domicile sur
le fil 69 à 68
ça a été très difficile mais on a su
relever la tête on va faire un dernier
quart-temps extraordinaire on va dire ça
nous a permis de repasser devant avant
les play offs ça fait du bien une
victoire comme ça parce que ça si on
avait perdu 2,17 points comme on essaie
à la fin ça aurait été difficile de
gagner les matches suivants
on revient grâce à nos shoots à trois
points
on a fait une belle série
on était très à droite à trois points et
on
avec cette victoire le
chesnay-versailles conserve la première
place de la poule e de nationale 3 avec
trois points d'avancé sur le 2e ruaudin
les basketteuses heavy noise font partie
des prétendants à la montée en nationale
2 un échelon qu'elles ont connu l'année
dernière
pour l'instant on prend chaque match
comédiens ont fait pas d'eux
on va pas plus loin que ça et on verra
mais ça se passe très bien
d'ailleurs un problème on attend les
derniers matches avec impatience et on
espère vraiment remonter en nationale 2
c'est niveau auquel on était dernier
suite à celle objectif il faut continuer
de travailler dur comme on a travaillé
rester concentré très parano playoffs
pass complet que nous devons avoir un
jeu très élevé aurait aussi les playoffs
débuteront en avril prochain mais avant
de penser à ces matches couperets qui
réuniront les meilleures équipes de la
division
le chesnay versailles devrait remporter
les cinq dernières journées du
championnat de nationale 3 la 31e
édition du marathon des sables est
programmé du 8 au 18 avril dans le
sahara marocain le concept les coureurs
doivent parcourir une distance de 250 km
en autosuffisance alimentaire avec
l'obligation de porter leur équipement
sur le trajet pour nous parler de la
compétition nous recevons sur ce plateau
gilles abobo qui participera à son
quatrième marathon des sables et laurent
cazes donne qui sera novice sur cette
épreuve en avril prochain
bonsoir alors on va commencer par vous
gilles vous en être à vous mettre à
votre quatrième édition
pourquoi vous inscrivez vous chaque
année je m'inscris chaque année parce
que
c'est une épreuve qui est magique qui me
parlent beaucoup pourquoi parce que
c'est avant tout une aventure humaine
c'est une aventure sportive aussi dans
un cadre magique qui est le désert
marocain
et en plus c'est un c'est une manière
pendant une semaine de pouvoir se couper
complètement de l'événement de se couper
du monde et pouvoir vivre une vraie
aventure sportive pour vous laurent ça
sera votre premier par ascendant une
première participation avec tout le
suspense incertitudes et la difficulté
de la préparation donc une inscription
je crois qu'ils bien pour relever un
nouveau challenge
enfin vous êtes un habitué à longue
distance au fur et à mesure on commence
par la petite distance puis après on
passe au marathon puis on rallonge
encore un petit peu au trail de 80 km et
puissant km à millau et puis finalement
on arrive à l'épreuve ultime celle qu'on
compte on rêve qui est le marathon des
sables et votre vos proches on va j
comment cette annonce avec une certaine
inquiétude
il faut l'avouer
vous stoppez à vous arrêter à distance
de 250 km de rails une certaine habitude
par rapport à des épreuves de plus en
plus longues que je fais chaque année
mais c'est vrai que 250 kilomètres ça
paraît une énorme montagne à gravir
de votre côté vos proches réagissent
comme en afrique assure vous partez
alors écoutez de mon côté ce relais
c'est ma quatrième édition mais la
deuxième et la troisième édition je
découvris avec ma femme
donc on a pu même le faire en famille
vous voyez et avec plein de copains donc
nos proches dont ils voient ça d'un oeil
ap toujours tu es fou mais
mais bon il voit revenir en bon état et
puis voir partir alors qu'ils sont
plutôt rassurés ça leur donne envie
peut-être des participants il ya
beaucoup de copains qui j'ai donné envie
de effectivement de de faire le marathon
des sables d'ailleurs
chaque année on est toujours un peu plus
nombreux et c'est parce que il ya une
ambiance dans le bivouac qui est très en
fait c'est une grande famille de plus de
1000 personnes c'est une sorte de
caravane qui part et à l'arrivée il n'y
a que des vainqueurs
justement il ya un esprit de compétition
où il ya justement cet esprit un peu de
bonne humeur on y va ensemble pourra pas
réussir à un exploit il s'agit d'une
course donc il ya un esprit de
compétition c'est une course mais
l'esprit de compétition vraiment forcée
pour les 50 premiers et puis voir - et
mais de toute façon il ya une humilité
qui est qui et qui est incroyable de
tous les participants et chacun qui
arrive c'est une victoire
donc en fait on est tous des gagnants le
gagnant c'est celui qui arrive au bout
on s'entraide voilà pendant un autre est
énormément se donne d'aider tous les
tuyaux qu'on peut avoir on on laisse
jamais quelqu'un sur le bord du chemin
dans cette course est ce que vous êtes
entraîné durement pour cette compétition
alors certes un entraînement qui est sur
la durée qui oblige à courir entre 60 et
100 120 km par semaine sinon sont
s'entraîner correctement pendant
plusieurs mois et idéalement sur les
courses de trail qui a qui ont lieu dans
la région des yvelines au règne de
france et puis aussi sur les rotules
mandé parcours un petit peu plus longs
comme je fais assez régulièrement sur le
100 km de millau les courses encore plus
longue à berlin tout le monde peut faire
ce marathon des sables dans l'histoire
du marathon des sables il eu un jeune de
16 ans a moins jeunes de 79 ans qui a
participé à la compétition
tout peut réellement faire ce marathon
des sables où il faut quand même avoir
cet entraînement commun comme le disait
il ya quelques instants
il faut de l'entraînement il faut une
bonne condition physique minimum
effectivement cinq ans soit 160 km par
semaine
mais tout le monde peut le faire parce
que on a du temps pour faire cette
course les barrières horaires sont assez
lâche donc en fait on on peut y arriver
si on a une vraie volonté et un mental
d'enfer
soixante ans c'est quand même et oui oui
mais si elle est dure et dure un peu à
la douleur cette personne et si elle a
un mental d'enfer
elle y arrivera et en combien de temps
en réalise généralement l'épreuve
alors justement les premiers real e-vlan
réalise l'ensemble de l'épreuve je crois
en une vingtaine d'heures et les
derniers soins 70 heures donc vous voyez
un peu l'amplitude ce qui fait que
on a vraiment beaucoup de temps pour
pouvoir y arriver comment faut-il géré
sa course
il faut partir très vite tout de suite
où il faut gérer ce sont en marchant
courant alors ainsi que je ne suis pas
le familier de la course encore d'une
façon générale d'une façon générale sur
les sur les courses de très longues
distances il faut partir modérément d'un
pas léger sans forcer parce que c'est
des courses donc il faut gérer la
distance donc à l'économie je pense que
là dans cette épreuve des trois premiers
jours sur des distances relativement
courte
la grosse journée et des deux journées
sont difficiles sont le quatrième et le
cinquième jour avec une distance de 100
km et donc il faut qu'il faut se
préparer pour les 100 km qui sont au
milieu de l'épreuve d'accord validé
alors oui c'est là les deux principaux
points quand entièrement bien sûr
chantier - d'accord et ensuite en fait
les principales difficultés du marathon
des sables
c'est la chaleur la chaleur on a quand
un téléthon pour lutter contre ça on
peut rien faire donc voilà on boit on
voit et puis on prend son mal en
patience
on a un sac à dos de 8 à 10 kilos sur le
dos puisque non de toute suffisance
alimentaire donc en autosuffisance
complètement donc à sac à dos la chaleur
et les pieds voilà cdc les trois
éléments différenciants de cette course
par rapport à d'autres et comment
gère-t-on seront sous l'eau justement et
bien son dos elle nous est dit on à en
bois à peu près 10 litres d'eau par jour
et nous est distribué à chaque
checkpoint et il faut savoir bien la
gérer et quels sont vos objectifs sur
cette compétition vous en êtes à votre
quatrième édition
quels sont vos objectifs vous voulez
monter un petit peu plus au classement à
chaque fois non on va se prendre du
plaisir
moi c'est vraiment prendre du plaisir
j'y vais avec des copains on
on va se retrouver au bivouac pas trop
souffrir
je vais souffrir mais j'espère pas trop
et prendre du plaisir parce que les
sites sont merveilleux puis c'est encore
une fois c'est une grande famille donc
voilà ce que je veux c'est en profiter
et bien sûr faire le meilleur score
possible
et vous alors c'est la même chose
victoire sur la laisse aux habitués
d'ailleurs de la victoire ils sont à peu
près les mêmes chaque année depuis
quelques années l'objectif c'est avant
tout de profiter prend du plaisir c'est
une course en nature c'est un trade
distance mais c'est dans le désert dans
les conditions difficiles faut prendre
soin de ses pieds de la température
boire beaucoup d'eau et le seul objectif
c'est de terminer on se faisant plaisir
c'est avant tout une aventure humaine
c'est toujours un challenge contre soi
même
sur ce genre d'épreuve la distance la
durée fait que oui on se met un petit
peu contre soi-même en même temps merci
à tous de passer sur ce plateau bon
courage pour votre périple
on prendra des nouvelles de vous à
l'arrivée on passe maintenant à
l'essentiel de l'actualité sportive
cette page par du rugby en fédérale 3
l'équipe senior de chevreuse s'est
incliné contre chinon à domicile lors de
la 14e journée du championnat le score
24 à 15 au classement chevreuse recul
d'une place et occupe désormais l'avant
dernière place derrière joué-lès-tours
il prend une position synonyme de
relégation à la fin de la saison il
reste quatre matches aux chevrons autun
pour se sauver
toujours en rugby est toujours en
fédérale 3 plaisir n'en finit plus de
gagner
les plaisirs oies en engranger leurs
traits et victoires en 14 matches
disputés cette saison contre marcq en
baroeul le score est sans appel à 50 9 à
au classement plaisir est évidemment
tête avec un point d'avancé sur le
second ris orangis la montée l'objectif
fixé en début de saison est donc plus
que jamais envisageable
on referme ce magazine à part deux dates
le premier rendez-vous concerne le
cyclisme sur piste les championnats du
monde sont programmés à partir de
mercredi jusqu'à dimanche à londres en
angleterre
parmi les concurrents on retrouve
plusieurs divine oilily montrent un
françois pervis s'est tentera de faire
aussi bien que lors des championnats du
monde 2015 où il avait remporté deux
médailles d'or à saint quentin en
yvelines
son principal concurrent devrait être un
autre événement grégory baugé le
cycliste originaire de maisons laffitte
neuf fois champion du monde sera aligné
dans les mêmes épreuves que françois
pervis le plaisir roi michael d'almeida
tentera lui de remporter des médailles
dans les épreuves de sprint
chez les dames sandie clair qui habite à
plaisir va essayer de monter sur le
podium en vitesse individuelle
objectif annoncé par la fédération raflé
au moins cinq médailles pour préparer
les jeux olympiques de cet été à rio et
on termine par la célèbre compétition
cycliste paris nice pour la septième
année consécutive la course organisée du
6 au 13 mars s'élancera depuis les
yvelines la ville de conflans sainte
honorine a été choisi pour le prologue
de cette soixante quatorzième édition
avec au programme 6 km avec le fameux
sentier des laveuses une cote de 200 m
une deuxième vie libinois sera également
à l'honneur sur ce paris-nice 2016 condé
sur vègre
159 habitants a été sélectionnée pour
accueillir le départ de la première
étape de la compétition
une première pour ce village situé près
de rambouillet une centaine de corps est
attendu sur paris nice parmi les têtes
d'affiché on retrouvera les stars
françaises romain bardet et tony
gallopin italien fabio aru et l'espagnol
alberto contador vainqueur du tour de
france et vainqueur de l'épreuve en 2007
et 2010
c'est la fin de six sept huit sports
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à 10
il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78